-After lying and claiming
he was unhappy
with the racist chants
he inspired last week,
the President is back
to attacking
four Democratic Congresswomen
of color.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Last week, after he incited
a crowd at his rally
to chant "Send her back"
about Minnesota Congresswoman
Ilhan Omar,
an American citizen
and Somali refugee,
Trump initially claimed
to be unhappy about the chant
he inspired,
which was obviously BS.
It's like if Mr. Met started
pumping up a crowd at a game,
and then when they chanted
"Let's go, Mets,"
he said,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, guys!
That is uncalled for!"
Donald Trump is not known
for disavowing racism.
In fact, he won't disavow
anyone who supports
or praises him because
he's a raging narcissist.
He rails against communism,
but if Mao came back from
the dead and endorsed him,
Trump would start wearing tunics
the next day.
[ Laughter ]
We've been here before
countless times.
Like the time he repeatedly
refused to disavow
the support of former KKK leader
David Duke,
and then later lied and said
it was because he couldn't
hear the question.
-He says, "I'm just talking
about David Duke
and the Ku Klux Klan here,"
and you said,
"Honestly, I don't know
David Duke."
-Let me tell you. Okay.
So, let me tell you.
I'm sitting in a house
in Florida
with a very bad ear piece
that they gave me,
and you could hardly hear
what he was saying.
-Even when he lies,
he sounds like an addled grandpa
FaceTiming with his grandkids
from a nursing home.
[ As Trump ] I'm here
in this house in Florida.
I can't hardly hear
what you're saying.
My ear trumpet is on the fritz."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] And then
there was Trump's reaction
to Charlottesville
when he refused to condemn
neo-Nazis
and white supremacists.
Two days later, Trump's advisors
again had to wrangle him
to issue a statement disavowing
the white supremacists,
and it was against
Trump's wishes.
Aides tried to convince
the president
he needed to clarify
his remarks,
but Trump appeared to resist
repeatedly saying,
"I don't know about this.
This doesn't feel right to me."
And then after he gave
the speech,
Trump told his aides,
"That was the biggest [bleep]
mistake I've made.
That's the worst speech
I've ever given."
You think that's the worst
speech you've ever given?
Dude, you've given speeches
that technically
don't even qualify
as human speech.
-There's another
crucial election
in North Carolina's Nith Conge--
You know, right?
10,000 known or suspested
gang members.
God bless the United Shtates.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump has repeatedly refused
to disavow racism
because he's a racist
and the core of his world view
is that citizenship for nonwhite
people is conditional.
If you don't praise him,
you're not a legitimate citizen,
which is why he can't stop
mounting racist attacks
on the four
Democratic Congresswomen
known as the Squad,
repeating those attacks
in unhinged tweets on Sunday
and again today.
-The President tweeting,
"I don't believe
the four Congresswomen are
capable of loving our country.
They should apologize to America
and Israel for the horrible,
hateful things they have said.
They are destroying
the Democratic Party,
but are weak and insecure people
who can never destroy
our great nation."
-"The squad is a very racist
group of troublemakers
who are young, inexperienced,
and not very smart."
-All right, first of all, you're
calling them troublemakers?
Are you trying to sound like
a Scooby-Doo villain?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it would make sense
since your face looks like
a Halloween mask.
His presidency should end
with the gang tieing him up
in an abandoned amusement park.
[ Laughter ]
Second, it never stops
being amazing to me
how much he projects
onto other people.
He called them weak, insecure,
racist, inexperienced,
and not very smart.
What's next?
[ As Trump ] "They can't
even pronounce basic words.
That's why they hate the --
-United Shtates.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
But while Trump...
[ Cheers and applause ]
While Trump was waging
his racist attacks last week,
we found out about
yet another potential crime
that almost certainly would have
landed Trump in a courtroom
if he were not the president.
First, let's just remember
that right now,
one big reason Trump
hasn't been charged with a crime
is the fact that
Justice Department guidelines
say a sitting President
cannot be indicted,
and that's not explicitly
written
in the Constitution or anything.
It started with a memo
that's more than 40 years old.
-We have that policy thanks
to a man named Robert Dixon
who was the head
of the Department of Justice's
Office of Legal Counsel
way back in 1973
when they authored a memo
that says a president
cannot be indicted
while sitting in office.
-That's right.
Trump can't be indicted
because of a memo
written in 1973.
People ignore memos every day.
We sent out 15 memos,
but Devon's still microwaving
fish in the break room.
[ Laughter ]
Those guidelines are part of why
Robert Mueller
didn't charge Trump with
obstructions of justice.
In fact, Mueller will testify
on Wednesday in Congress
where he will surely be asked
point blank by Democrats
if Trump would have been
indicted had it not been
for those guidelines,
and today in the oval office,
Trump pretended like he wouldn't
be paying that much attention
to the hearings.
-No, I'm not going to be
watching.
Probably. Maybe I'll see
a little bit of it.
I'm not going to be watching
Mueller
because you can't take all those
bites out of the apple.
He still ruled no collusion,
no obstruction,
and this thing should have ended
a long time ago.
This has been going on
for 2 1/2 years.
-No, I agree with you
that this thing
that's been going on
for 2 1/2 years
should have ended
a long time ago.
Also, no one believes you
when you say you're not
going to be watching.
All you do is watch TV.
If the Mueller hearings
weren't on,
you'd be live tweeting
"Days of Our Lives."
[ As Trump ] "Jessica's evil
twin is back from the dead.
Not nice!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And it's not just Mueller.
Last week, we also found out
that the Justice Department
guidelines
might be why Trump
wasn't charged with a crime
in the hush money schemes
he orchestrated
during the 2016 campaign
to cover up affairs,
which ultimately resulted
in his personal fixer,
Michael Cohen, going to jail.
Last week, we found out
that investigators
said that Trump was the one
who was directly involved
when a court unsealed documents
detailing Trump's communication
with Cohen to coordinate
the illegal hush payments.
-Breaking news.
New documents released last hour
prompting a very big
and very uncomfortable question
for the White House.
Did the president
commit a crime?
Today, a judge unsealed
search warrant materials
in connection to
the Michael Cohen case
and the effort to buy
the silence of women
who say they had affairs
with the president.
The documents mentioned
the president by name.
-According to the documents,
then-candidate Donald Trump
whose former attorney
and former aide, Hope Hicks,
may have discussed ways
to stop adult film star
Stormy Daniels from going public
about an alleged affair
with Trump.
According to
an FBI special agent
who wrote in the affidavit,
a series of phone calls
took place in October 2016
just before the election.
-A lead FBI investigating agent
writes in the documents,
"Based on the timing
of these calls
and the content of the text
messages and emails,
I believe at least
some of these communications
concern the need
to prevent Clifford,
a reference to Stormy Daniels,
from going public,
particularly in the wake
of the "Access Hollywood" story.
-The President was allegedly
involved in the cover-up
of a crime in the last weeks
of the presidential election,
and it wasn't even like in the
top ten news stories last week.
This is how he wears us down.
It's like being in
a zombie movie.
Anybody can outrun one zombie.
But when your city is crawling
with zombies,
you're like, [bleep] it.
Just eat me.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to not be --
I'll be a zombie, too.
We'll all be zombies.
This is the core of Trumpism.
He marries racism
with corrupt plutocracy.
It's not just his cabinet that's
been riddled with scandal.
He doled out tax cuts to the
wealthy and corporations,
slashed environmental
regulations,
and gutted consumer protections.
And, of course,
he's been personally profiting
off the presidency, himself.
-"Washington post" reports that
lobbyists representing
the Saudi government paid for
an estimated 500 rooms
at President Trump's D.C. hotel
in the months
after his election.
The total bill for those
trips -- more than $270,000.
-T-Mobile executives booked
dozens of nights
at the Trump hotel last year
once their merger
needed Trump administration
approval.
-NBC news has obtained documents
showing that
Trump International Hotel
billed the secret service
$215,000 for the period
between September 2016
and February 2018.
-President Trump's golf habit
has cost the American people
some $102 million and counting.
-So not only has the presidency
allowed Trump to commit
indictable offenses with
impunity, it's also allowed him
to personally profit
off the presidency.
I wouldn't be surprised if he
just started selling off pieces
of the oval office
on Craigslist.
"Good desk made of wood.
Has light ketchup stains."
[ Laughter ]
So Trump's base gets to revel
in his open racism
while he plunders the government
and doles out favors
and tax cuts
to his rich buddies.
Who knows if he'll ever be held
accountable for his crimes?
When it comes to
the Trump presidency,
one thing is clear --
-This thing should have ended
a long time ago.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪